si es una reunión de urgencia de última
hora en la que el secretario general del
organismo antonio guterres ha pedido
unidad ante lo que ha dicho considera
una amenaza terrorista mundial ha dicho
que las naciones unidas- no pueden
abandonar ni deben abandonar al pueblo
afgano y siguiendo todos los protocolos
de seguridad también ha indicado en que
nos quedaremos ha dicho y brindaremos
apoyo al pueblo afgano hemos escuchado
también en esta reunión del consejo de
seguridad de urgencia al representante
de afganistán que se ha mostrado
preocupado por la situación y por los
buenos propósitos de los talibanes le
preocupa que se están haciendo ya
registros domiciliarios con la intención
de deshacerse de los opositores la
representante de eeuu ha pedido la
seguridad para los civiles nacionales
internacionales ha dicho que todos
aquellos que quieran salir del país
deberían poder hacerlo de una manera
segura si no ha dicho habrá una
respuesta militar ha pedido también a
los países de alrededor de afganistán
que den refugio a aquellas personas que
están huyendo méjico como muchos otros
representantes ha pedido el fin de la
vía y ha dicho que afganistán no debe
convertirse en un refugio para los
terroristas y rusia que ha convocado que
ha sido uno de los países que ha pedido
convocar esta reunión ha dicho que de
momento y su embajada está operando de
manera normal y que los siguientes pasos
dependerán de la actuación de los
talibanes